now the ukrainians tonight they are
battling for their capital they are
putting up a strong resistance and
volunteer fighters are now reportedly
patrolling central keeve as russian
forces are now closing in and one member
of the ukrainian parliament kira rudick
is saying that she is armed she is ready
to fight as putin now invades the
country she joins us now with the latest
developments on the ground uh
you it's very brave of views thank you
for being with us what's the latest
where you are
hello good evening so i'm in kiev right
now as you see i'm sitting on top of the
stairs this means that there is no
air force attack because if
there is and there is a siren then i go
with my family under the stairs and this
is where we hide
when there is no air force attack uh
we are gathering together to the
self-defense or resistant groups and
then help to patrol the city and i'm
super proud that the
teams that are right now um patrolling
the city they are actually
removing
many russian soldiers who were trying to
get in because our army is working on
the strategic objects and then the
self-defense or territorial defense
groups are helping out to clean up the
mess if there is a mess
you know kyra um it's very brave of you
to stay
it's brave of many other of your fellow
countrymen to fight
it's a david and goliath scenario you
are outmanned you are outgunned uh the
russian army has proven itself so far to
be brutal
uh usually in cases like this
when
if in fact the capital does fall as many
are predicting in the next 48 72 hours i
hope it doesn't happen in keeve
if it happens you know that you will be
on that list of targets just like
president zielinski who is there in kiev
and saying that he is not leaving he's
staying and fighting to the end
well will your fellow
politicians do the same thing
i do understand that and it was my
honest decision to
stay here and not to flee
first of all because i'm a politician
and
i'm representing all my people and they
didn't go anywhere
second because
it's i woke up
i looked at all of this and i just was
thinking like why
why would we do this like why would we
um
go away
he's coming to our land with his forces
and
we are able to fight him back and we are
actually doing it very good so at in two
days he lost putin lost like 3 000 men
which is uh probably the most that he
lost in the latest
uh wars that he was
fighting like throughout the world so
ukrainian army is biting him
very very hard and we we are resisting
in in the best ways of
the resistance
so that's why i believe that we will be
able to fight back there is indeed uh
something that really would help out is
the no-fly zone that my party and i we
have been asking for it like for the
last i don't know three months or so
where it started with like yeah no it
started with oh no we cannot help you to
okay let us see what we can do but this
is actually
um a very very very not smart move from
nato and from the allies because
look guys if we fail
next is poland or next are baltic
countries uh what is the world going to
do with that so that's why we are
fighting for like bigger and general
idea of the new security order that is
going to be established because as you
said before
right now there is like no force no
force
the world is not serious if they're not
going to sanction russia and putin on
oil and gas because that's the lifeblood
that he needs to pursue his territorial
ambitions
i pray for you and your family i pray
for your country
i've had criticisms about some of the
government corruption over the years
this is an independent country
and this is an invasion
by a thug and a tyrant under false
pretenses and you have a right to fight
for your country and we wish you
godspeed and i hope that the world will
help you in terms of providing ornaments
available to you so that you can make
that fight and take that fight and build
an insurgency that is uh
effective against the russian army and
their might that they have and their
advantage that they have
godspeed kyra and we'll be in touch
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else